/ disagreable and Maurice Maurice thanks
guys we are with a very special person
Vladimir Putin who is the trainer of
Yana Pagliacci the current leader in the
event now that Amir has been the
European champion that he did in 2011
he's peak rating of 2686 so a strong
player in his own right he was also the
coach of one Sergey Kuryakin during the
World Championship campaign that saw
Sergei be just that close to nipping at
the heels of Magnus Carlsen so clearly
you've seen a lot at the top of world
chess welcome to the show it's nice to
meet you
first of all let's let's get down to it
Yanis is doing so well could you guys
have imagined when you were coming to
the event that he'd be +3 Lear ahead of
the hardest player in the world Magnus
Carlsen and everybody else of course you
can't expect anything and kills at
odometer circuit but Ian is in good
shape he won Moscow Grand Prix and he's
really motivated for this period because
he has plenty of tournaments and he is
really enjoying to play with strong
players in the world and he is super
motivated you mentioned that you've been
working with him for 10 years now and
that lately he's been inviting you to
everything so you can't even do it he
just playing yourself that must make you
feel good to know that you're your
charge has such confidence in you yes
since GM is doing very good on the
tournaments so I just can't worry myself
because I became and young is very
maturity time they see in his eyes how
he lost just now and for me is most of
important when the player is motivated
and he loves what he is doing so it's a
great pleasure to help at that moment
what do you see as his qualities and may
separate him from other top players what
or just what's special about him as a
player person I think he honest really
wants to fight and when he's playing
chess he just enjoys the game and he can
make some revelation and really can
calculate many variations so he doesn't
stop at some classical approach
so he wants to create something new and
he's studying and he is a person who is
not only an orphan share so he making
some games on sports so his big
personality you mentioned something I've
noticed his speed of plays quickness in
decision-making he seems confident that
when he knows this is the case he just
goes for it instead of spending a lot of
time on the clock I know when I started
to my coaching first my experience was
great Levon Aronian one ski player won
he won the Linares tournament and he
also some period he played extremely
fast so I think once the player belief
in his self he is really motivated and
he doesn't need an extra time to sink
and he just sees the moving he just make
it and I think you know in the old times
when it was a big time control it was
considered when he sees a good move I
look for another one but now when he
sees the would move just make it very
interesting observation the fact that
this tournament it hasn't necessarily
been one of those clean-cut Affairs like
he just dominating the opposition he's
had some rocky positions yes row so very
shaky position Center can end for
anything but I think he honest big
fighter so I despite of the suspicious
position he is just making the best
moves and tried to make some tricks for
example let's say Magnus on his points
is best in celebration sometimes he also
make out of risk so I think
Yanis getting some of the Magnus has
protein as well so we are studying we
are getting every best part of it anyway
area absolutely steal whatever you can
it's not stealing if it works this
position we've got in front of us with
him versus ding Lorena this one looks
like a tough one his pawns are not
exactly all together his King still not
counseled yet did you prepare this line
specifically or do you feel like he may
have been surprised in this particular
position
well of course already players on our
own and position looks dangerous but I
believe in Yun and I think he'll create
some stress so just now he should solve
the question of his King
and maybe even exchanging prints it's
not about outcomes opening in this
position tell me I'm gonna flip side
it's you know it all sounds like it's a
love affair when you working with your
your your a man in yarn but it's not
always that a student or player will
listen to the coach what kind of
discussions do you guys get in any
arguments that you might think I like
this and he goes no no we're gonna do
this no of course it's always a
discussion so I'm trying that player
takes the decision and he takes it from
his own heart so I will not force player
if I am extremely confident just to play
the slide because I need the players
that he thinks that it's his decision
and then he get more confidence in this
station absolutely you're a top coach
you're feeling when you're watching
you're not you had your own feeling
you're a serious player yourself
European champion very strong player
what's the difference between you
playing and watching him play because
it's it's every move you have to be
concerned about and you have no control
over what's happening on the board of
course it's completely different because
when I study Young's game of course at
some moment I can take very strong
decisions I think but to take
concentration during all the game is a
completely different story so to take
one or two or three strong decisions not
enough to make his game so you need to
make concentration and it's a completely
different to see the game and to play
the game once you are involved in
playing you're already fighting and it's
another story you need some fighting
abilities and to keep all this
concentration till twos and how nervous
did you get watching him play I tried
not to know us yet because I feel that
he honors of course in the game and if I
will be nervous the same as young and it
will be I think not so good I need to
stay calm in essence cetacean alright
well thanks for spending some time with
us we really appreciate it and good luck
for the rest of this warming Thank You
Maurice playing Viking and good luck to
you very important the trainer of young
upon the
she clearly doing a great job thank you